السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره افادت وكالته
اسرشيتد بريس باحتفاظ الديمقراطيين
بالاغلبيه البسيطه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي بعد فوز مرشحه الحزب كاترين
كارتيزم ماستو بمقعد المجلس عن الولايات
نيفادا وذلك في انتخابات التجديديه النصفي
ويملك الديمقراطيون حاليا 50 مقعدا اضافتا
لوجود صوت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كمل حارس
التي تتراس مجلس الشيوخ مقابله 49 على
الجمهوريين من جهه اخرى افادت وكاله بريس
بارتفاع عدد مقاعد الديمقراطيين في مجلس
النواب الى
2004 مقابل 200 واحد 10 للجمهوريين حتى
اللحظه مع ترقق بنتائج الانتخابات في
ولايه تكاليفورنيا
وفي اول تعليق ان له بعد احتفال
الديمقراطيين بالاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه يشعر
بالسعاده بالغه بنتائج الانتخابات
الامريكيه النصفيه واقال بايدون في
تصريحات للصحافيين في كمبوديا ان انتباهه
منصب على نتيجه السباق للفوز بمقعد ولايه
جورجيا في مجلس الشيوخ حيث ستجرى جوله
ثانيه من الانتخابات بعد فشل المرشحين
الديمقراطي والجمهوريه في تخطي حاجز
الخمسين في المئه واضاف بعيدا ان نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه عزت وضعه سياسيه قبل
لقائه نظيره الصيني خلال قمه العشرين التي
تستضيفها اندونيسيا
قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليه الجنوب
الاوكرانيه ان قوتي بلادي اكتشفت دبابات
ومدافعه ومعدات روسيه في خرسون جنوبيه
البلاد بعد فشل الروس في عبور النهر دي
بروبها اثناء الانسحاب من المدينه واضافت
ان الجيش الاوكرانيه يجمعون ما يناسبهم
منها لاستخدامه في الهجوم المضاد
تحترم المعارك في اقليم اوكرانيا خصوصا في
محور مطار دونيسكولوجان وقد هجمت قوته
دونيت كالمواليه لروسيا مواقع للجيش
الاوكراني الشمالي مدينه دونيت وقالت
وكاله وريانوستي الروسيه ان القوات
المواليه
في المحور الشمالي للمدينه بعد سيطراتها
على عدد من المواقع الاكرانيه
قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي انه تم رصد
اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه الصناع في يد
القوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه خيرسون جنوبيه
اوكرانيا ونشر موقع الهيئه نقلا عن حساب
في التويتر يعنى بالاسلحه والعتاد
المستخدمه في الحرب الدائره هناك صورا
لاليات اسرائيليه في اوكرانيا
في اسرائيل عن اعتقاده ان ما سماه تحولا
استراتيجيا يلوح في الافقي مع عوده
بنيامين نتنياهو الى السلطه في اسرائيل
كثافه كيف اتصلاتها من اجل تمديد اتفاق
تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه عاما اضافيا على
الاقل ولتوسيعه ليشمل موانئه ميكولايف
يذكر ان اجل تطبيقيه لاتفاق ينتهي بعد
ثمانيه ايام من الان في الاثناء قالت
الخارجيه الروسيه ان العامل الحاسمه
لتمديد صفقه الحبوب هو تنفيذ الاتفاقيه
بشان تصدير المنتجات الزراعيه الروسيه قبل
التمديد بدوره رفض الرئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان ان يكون هناك حد زماني الاتفاق
واعرب عن طلوعه الى ان يؤسس الاتفاق طريقه
سلاما ينهي الحرب
وقعت الحكومه الاثيوبيه وجبهته تحريريه في
نيروبي وثيقه ترتيبات امنيه بواسطه
الافريقيه وذلك تثبيتا الاتفاق السلامي
بينهما لانهاء حرب استمرت عامين وتضمنت
الاتفاقيه وقفه اطلاق النار
وانهاء الاعمال القتاليه اضافه الى النزع
اسلحه الميليشيات بدوره قبل الوسيط
الافريقيين تنفيذ الاتفاق سيبدا فورا بفتح
المجال امام ايصال للمساعده الانسان من
جهاته قال قائد جبهه تحرير انهم ملتزمون
باتفاق السلام من اجل شعب التجراعي وقال
ممثل الحكومه الاثيوبيه ان الاتفاقا مع
جبهه يلزمهم بدمج الفصائل المسلحه وحل اي
نزاع سلمي»
اين كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل
[موسيقى]